hello freak [ __ ] personal thank you
so much my pleasure this is amazing well
dave rubin recommends you and I listen
to Dave room was not almost a whole lot
of people's recommendations but Dave
Rubin is one of them he's been an
amazing figure in my life just in the
last lesson even a month he just kind of
was like my Savior when like everyone
was you know kicking me while I was down
he was the one I kind of reached a hand
out and so I owe him a great deal well
we should kind of explain what kicking
you while you're down means because it's
it's more silly to me than anything
because it doesn't really make sense but
you tweeted a joke and it's a real
simple joke James TV pull up the joke
this is what happened Collin tweeted a
joke about a day without a woman and
everybody knows that a day without what
without a woman was like that day
without a Mexican thing or you were
supposed to like well imagine if there
were no women well if there were no
women first of all there'd be no [ __ ]
people
so yeah yes women are super important
for so you just write this tweet joke ah
peace and quiet hashtag a day without a
woman I would laugh everything was funny
and I would move on and that's it so
then I'll hold on a second put put it
put a look at look look go above that go
above that above it look at that
census tweet which was roundly condemned
as sexist yeah not really true if you
leave the gaming industry but radley
condemned in the gaming industry for
sure
outside of that people I think normal
everyday people that don't have an axe
to grind about literally everything
found it you know read it maybe groaned
or maybe laughter then kept going about
their day like a normal person you're
not allowed to have any personality no
if you work for any kind of a company
that is in any way public where you can
be targeted where they can say oh that's
the [ __ ] god go get them like
anything that's remotely controversial
and that is really remotely
controversial it's just al Bundy yeah I
mean it's not even a good joke and and
you know yes I heard you in Jim Norton
talking about by the way that video that
someone clip that out put it up on some
YouTube channel it's like that's like a
that videos like it going to be a relic
of my family forever everyone was like I
can't believe this what's going on this
is so great so I really do appreciate
you you know
stepping up when I got your DM by the
way on Twitter I was like this is what
an amazing turn of events this has been
for me so I really am appreciative you
again I just want you to know thank you
but stop saying you making my own comedy
awesome but uh but uh at the same time
you know I was in bed with my girlfriend
actually when I wrote it and I showed it
to her I was like it's kind of funny
right it's kind of stupid and she
laughed she she's a yarn nurse and she
worked the overnight shift so she was
just getting into bed as I was getting
up and she's like yeah that's funny then
we didn't really think twice about it I
sent it I got in the shower I went about
my day
and and then when I got to work I
realized that it was a much bigger deal
than I had thought
and it was and and then everything fell
apart and then was rebuilt very quickly
so well you resigned from the company
that you work for yeah I found it I've
closed out of the company yeah I owned a
piece and you resigned because of that
yeah yeah other reasons too but I mean
that was definitely the straw that broke
the camel's back for me and why in the
[ __ ] man yeah I was just I felt yeah how
is it how is it possible that in this
day and age that simple tweak by the way
if you reverse the sexes in that tweet
there's not a single man that would
complain and if he did he's not a man
yeah I agree and I say also that if a
person that wasn't a self-described like
moderate conservative or libertarian
sent that joke it also wouldn't have you
know gotten the firestorm that's the
thing Jo's but I don't think a liberal
man wouldn't have gotten a rash of [ __ ]
and then sort of I think it made him out
of the community maybe in a different
maybe in a different place but not in
the gaming industry which is almost
completely hyper liberal so I've had a
target on my back for years and that's I
think kind of the point I've lost on
some people is that this was just an
opportunity
no one was offended by this joke no one
was aghast like I said on Rubin the
second time I was on there I said like
no one was crying in their shower losing
sleep tossing and turning over to any
show and was well I hope so because
that's we should find that person a
person who studied them in a lab but to
me I was like no this is I mean it was
clear a few hours later when I finally
realized what was happening I'm like
this is they're in for the kill now this
is this as they found their way to get
me and so why do you think they wanted
to quote-unquote get you because you
know I live in San Francisco I've lived
there for ten years I was born and
raised on the Long Island but I went to
college in Boston and then I moved to
San Francisco
and it is as cartoonishly liberal as
everyone thinks it is so it's it's and
the gaming industry is there the gaming
media the people that write about games
and cover them and do all that kind of
stuff they're largely there and it's a
huge echo chamber they don't like when
people penetrate the echo chamber and I
made a name for myself in industry over
years I was the senior editor of the
biggest gaming website in the world for
years website IGN calm and and I was a
senior editor there and I made a name
for myself not only with criticism and
with long form pieces but but basically
I was writing pieces about political
correctness in 2011 and 2012 people
going after game developers people going
after all these things and me kind of
standing up and saying this isn't ok
this character assassination a good
example for everyone out there doesn't
know games there's this game called
Borderlands 2 one of the developers was
giving an interview about it he and this
was back in I think 2011 he said
something to the nature of this mode
this particular mode in the game is
accessible for everyone it's like a
girlfriend mode if you want your girl
from the competi he said a girl he
insinuated that women can't play games
and don't know how to play games
wherever by using the term girlfriend
loading people went after this guy and
tried to get him you know and I wrote
this piece saying like what the hell is
everyone doing this guy just is trying
to explain something he's not a sexist
why do you make these assumptions based
on this one thing about him and why do
you want to ruin someone and that's the
whole thing they want to ruin people so
I was outspoken about this and I was
outspoken for my support of Mitt Romney
and I was outspoken about my support for
Gary Johnson in my house book so they
don't like that they don't like that
stuff and and and I think that's pretty
clear now so you feel like there's a
sort of a reinforced type of thinking
like a very liberal reinforced type of
thinking that you must subscribe to if
you want to be a part of this
yes it's an orthodoxy it's a complete
and utter orthodoxy and it's it's it's
what's so kind of nice about this like
the unintended consequence that I think
is the silver lining of the dark cloud
is people from the outside now saw
firsthand like what I had been saying
for a long time which was which was like
I was kind of on the fringe I was kind
of being pushed out and I got that
literally thousands of people tweeting I
mean Facebook messaging me and doing
everything like wow this is [ __ ]
crazy these people really are out to get
you based on that you know you would
think I'd some horrible just offensive
just truly awful thing do
really out to get you or do you think
they're capitalizing on a moment where
they feel like you have a target on you
and they like kick them he's down we got
them and India's but this reaction
culture that we have like this over
overreaction culture that we find
herself in today it really does seem to
foster that kind of behavior that people
really like it when someone gets caught
doing something or when someone says
something inappropriate when you can
just point the finger and then everybody
can pile on yeah I think well let me put
it at different because I think you're
probably right in a sense in the sense
that I I never gained the benefit of the
doubt with this group let's put it that
way right so it was one thing which is
one thing the dominoes tip and it was
and that and they were down as opposed
to that's why I brought up the example
before if one of the people that they
actually liked within that insular
industry said the same thing they might
have been aghast but they may might have
reached a hand out or given that person
a second chance so I think that that all
plays in into the you know I have the
Gadsden flag as my Twitter I kind of had
that first since 2009 I have you know
I've not been shot at and flag being
don't tread on ready to snake right
exactly um you know I so there are just
certain things that made me very
different than other people in the
industry and I think I definitely think
that that plays well your twitter name
is no taxation yet which is a reference
to the American Revolution which I know
you know a lot of people think well you
know no taxes I'm like that's not what
it means I can't I can't fit no taxation
without representation on Twitter that's
why it doesn't say that yeah that would
be a long yeah yeah not necessarily long
you'd have no room for tweets but it
would make you very economical with your
word yes that's what I love about
Twitter you probably feel the same way I
write something really long time then I
have to parse it and figure out how to
make it fit and it feels very good for
joke writing like for the skill of joke
writing to make to make things more
concise like I always tell people that I
think the greatest joke writer or the
greatest comedian is Joey Diaz because
he says he gives you the most amount of
visuals and impact with the least amount
of words
it's just bah bah bah bah bah bah he
knows how to like sink it in really
quickly and Twitter's like a good tool
for that but not if that's a little
ridiculous that's because you only bit
back I don't know if that's the case how
it is now but well actually it
definitely is right like if I write to
you um if I reply to you your name takes
up a big chunk of what I tweet right you
you what you tweet doesn't take up so
it's like the 140 characters would be
limiting people that respond to you
rather than you tweeting yeah exactly
and the beauty is to as you've probably
noticed is that I think in the last year
whatever they were images used to take
up characters you know and then in the
videos and links and I think the links
are the only thing left that takes up
the extra characters in addition to the
name but it keeps everyone curt but that
doesn't stop people from tweeting 7,000
times in a row and put numbers on the
mug on it - yeah I know I I did it just
yesterday when I ran into some woman in
San Francisco that I was walking my dog
I have a Boston Terrier she was like a
little sicker her poop was a little wet
so I went and picked it up and I left
like some here just like schmear you'd
have to use your fingernails to get off
the ground so a woman came out of her
apartment and started scolding me like
she was waiting by the by the window to
scold me for this and I like what the
hell is going on so I had to tweet out a
few tweets about that just for posterity
yeah the Twitter thing is very weird but
here's something that I really don't
like and I'm glad I don't see much of it
anymore is that twit longer [ __ ] hey
that's a loophole yeah we don't do that
don't do that
Ralphy Mays do that [ __ ] all the time
these two retweets like what the [ __ ]
Ralphy why are you writing paragraphs
here you know what's going on yeah some
people you know I've got to a foot world
like going in Photoshop make a paragraph
of a text and make that the image that
you have to do that on the Instagram -
oh yeah I've done that before I've drawn
written things down then taking a photo
I said I was going to do that for a
while but I think that Twitter is just
too impersonal I'm going to write all my
stuff out and take a picture of it I was
just [ __ ] on I think if that's the
except like if it's the exception I
think it's totally fine i don't want
people ruining twitter that I like the
Curtis yeah it's good it's good format
but it also makes it extremely easy for
people to do what happen to you yes
exactly because there's nuances lost
right yeah life is long well it's always
lost in text I mean what we're in
writing it's very difficult even if
you're reading a book sometimes you have
to go over the previous paragraphs to
figure out exactly how this guy was
setting this up but I think what's
what's happening what you're saying I
see there's two parts there's like one
like the example he gave before about
the guy saying that it's like girlfriend
mode if he just said it's like say if
your girlfriend doesn't play video games
and she wants a really easily
accessible you could do it that way but
I think people probably would attack
them even for that yeah it would say
what are you implying that girls don't
play video games well that's simple it's
always the implication right like
everyone's always out to assume the
absolute worst and now so I was trying
to write about like this guy is just
trying to make an example he's probably
given 15 PR interviews today he's
probably exhausted he's also a developer
so he doesn't have much PR training
right he's trying to just get the point
across why do you have to assume the man
is a sexist and misogynist because of
this one thing it's I'm willing to die
on that hill because I feel like people
deserve the benefit of the doubt people
deserve to make a mistake or get a joke
wrong or you know all those kinds of
things and I feel like yes people are
allowed to exercise their free speech on
the other enemy like I don't like that
joke or I don't like this or I don't
like that but it's net it doesn't stop
there
with what's going on with Dave Chappelle
this week I thought it was really
actually interesting with his two
specials on Netflix hmm people are
freaking out about you know his jokes is
his jokes about gay people or
transgender people whatever when I
compared transgender people to black
people and you know saying that it's
ridiculous comparison right like like I
actually after I saw the compel all the
stuff I went and watched the first one
then I watched half of the second one
and I'm falling asleep so I didn't want
to watch anymore but I was like this is
funny and Anthony Jeselnik or Daniel
Tosh would make these people [ __ ] their
pants compared to what's going on with
this kind of stuff and and it's always
this drama that that seeks to kind of it
doesn't stop it saying like I don't like
it it's often insinuated or outright
spoken that they want to censor it or
change it that's like where I because I
was reading a piece specifically about
Chappelle where they're like this calls
up questions as to what like how far
should comedy go and I'm like no that's
uh that doesn't call and that's when the
free speech argument ends for me that's
what I'm like you're actually now
talking about changing it well it
doesn't work it doesn't work with us
with comics it just doesn't work we're
not going to do it it's too many people
like it I understand what they're trying
to do because when they live in that
world of cubicles and human resources
and very restricted patterns of behavior
that you have to follow if you live in
an office environment and work in an
office environment rather you know
there's a lot of people out there that
are boxed into these terrible situations
where you have to pretend to be this
thing that you're not and you again you
don't have any personality you don't
you're not allowed to
ridiculous or silly and when you you
have that kind of environment and you
see someone was free like dave chappelle
you you want to stop it you and if you
can if you could point something out
that can outlook he's saying something
that's inappropriate he's saying
something I don't agree with he's saying
something let's get them let's go get
them and then also in defense of the
writers that are writing these articles
look they're in a bizarre environment
where they have to [ __ ] constantly
defend like their position they have to
constantly get clicks they have to
constantly get hits they can't just put
an article out and nobody reads it
they'll lose their job so they have to
write about something that's
inflammatory write about something
that's salacious something that's going
to get people excited I mean that guy
that wrote that thing about you for the
International Business Times I looked
into that International Business Times
and one of the things about it is that
there was a think was a mother jones
article about that website where they
were told like that the people who write
articles were given some ridiculous task
like they have to get 10,000 hits per
article day right right so that might
have for people don't know there was a
guy who wrote an article about Colin
where it said kind of funnies Colin
Moriarty was resigns after writing a
joke a racist joke that targeted women
it was a racist even remote them in the
slightest but when you take into account
the environment that these people are
forced to work in and you say well this
guy literally is forced to write
something that's more [ __ ] up than it
really is so you have to get people
excited about this in a way that's going
to get them to click on it and hopefully
get him to his ten thousand hit quota if
that is true I feel for him in a way I
feel I mean I think he's working for a
shitty business you know right but it's
the same way I feel I mean I actually
you know I came from the editorial world
where you have to get clear I mean we
were get it we our expectations are way
higher and you know but you have those
kind of requirements no not literally I
know some sites do but when we decide to
have like a quota yeah like a quota or
like you get bonuses if you get you know
certain amount of hits or whatever we
didn't have that we were salaried
whatever but you would if you would be
fired all tomorrow writing things that
people were reading right but I tried to
stay out of my way for you know writing
laboratory things actually there are a
couple of examples where I wouldn't
write a story because I felt like it
wasn't pertinent to any information and
it was specifically to assassinate
someone care about a problem here
you have [ __ ] morals dude yeah it was
the door yeah yeah like no room in this
business I had a I had a hype a high
profile woman in the gaming industry
tell me in an interview that was
unrelated to what I was actually
interviewing her that she'd never was
once the victim of sexism in the
industry ever and that was and I was
like I could write this but this isn't
why I was there you know I was an
interviewer about this and this is going
to cause her problems and that's not who
I am I don't cause a problem because
then people are gonna then people are
gonna you know jump on a belay wall you
know I experienced this and I
experienced this and you're diminishing
it would just cause a drama like why
would I do that it's not see this is
where it drives me crazy that's a
beautiful example of people being cool
if she can say hey I've never
experienced any sexism in this business
and you'd be like wow the gaming
industry must be really cool and this
woman has managed to get through the
maze with a bunch of high fives and
people appreciating her work wouldn't
that be celebrated mmm I'm not in the
gaming leshiy bit you know what I'm
saying like why does that have to be in
some ways a target like why is that
story of target like wouldn't you assume
that if there is a person who can reach
a high level prominence in this very
complicated business right I mean the
gaming industry is incredibly
complicated especially how weighted
everything is when it comes to male
versus female to have that whole
gamergate [ __ ] exposed so much of that
which was really confusing to people in
the outside especially people like me
who don't play game right I was like
what in the [ __ ] is you wanna make these
gamer people yes it's confusing me too I
mean if you if you run into someone who
is in any way involved in a sort of a
dispute that makes that person appear to
be a sexist you're supposed to pile on
yeah and and and and that's exactly what
they did and everything that hurt me the
most is that I didn't explose with a lot
of these people but people that know me
you know there are people in this
industry that are writing that were
piling on their remaining silent that
got freelance work because of me that
got maybe even got hired because I was
on a hiring committee that put you know
push for them all these kinds of things
and I people used to take out to lunch
when I was senior editor to see
they were doing if there's anything I
can do for them some like that and
everyone's just like no not going to say
I'm not going to come back and help him
out now and I tried to put that good
energy out there I'm not always full of
good energy sometimes I say negative
things are bad things sometimes I make
mistakes but when it come when a person
comes after your character and you damn
well know that there are a bunch of
people around you that know who you are
whether or not they agree with what you
said or agree with what you do but they
know you're who you are and they know
the severity of what people are saying
and they don't say anything that really
wounds a person and that really [ __ ]
hurt do you think that what's going on
in a lot of ways when people did not
come to your defense is that what you're
doing um in many ways is making a very
complicated and nuanced perspective from
a person in your in your stance you're
you're kind of you're taking this this
this path outside of the ideology and by
doing so you sort of challenge a lot of
the ways these people have been behaving
for a long time and as soon as you do
that they have to kind of reconsider
these ideological boundaries they've set
up in their own behavior and thinking
and communication and that they don't
want to do that and they didn't want to
do that like to keep things rigid and
simple and they also want to continue to
progress in their career and in order to
do that you have to kind of like have
this predetermined pattern that you
follow I think simple is the key word
that you use ensel because yes they
can't there are people out there that
cannot comprehend how a person who
believes in small government for
instance will use the same argument that
says the government can't touch my guns
that's consistent with saying the
government can't tell a woman what to do
with her body right that's consistent
with the principle says a government
shouldn't even be involved in telling
you who you can marry and a mannequin
should be able to marry man and a woman
should be able to marry a woman and I
would go as far as to say that even a
polygamist totally on the up-and-up
everyone's in on it relationship should
not the government that governs our
grants they cannot acknowledge that it's
the lack of governmental power that
gives you that right in my perspective
when they feel like it's the wielding of
government power that insures those
those rights that's not that's not
congruent them they don't understand how
we they don't understand how we came to
the same exact conclusion by going just
totally to differ
directions and that's really that
challenges them and they don't have the
philosophical boundary bounding to
figure out how that might be it's always
been a real real fascinating part and
now that you've left your company the
which was what was it called kind of
climbing up on yet and what was kind of
funny kind of funny was the four of us
that sounded the company were all at IGN
in different respects and we spun off to
just start our own YouTube channel about
games and nerd culture and stuff like
that do podcasts and we found some some
good successful most of a crowd funded
on patreon and it was a lot of fun and I
enjoyed it but I felt like I needed to
leave because I felt like that was the
best for everybody but once that what I
mean how could you not they turned on
you over that stupid [ __ ] joke yeah I
mean it's like not as a stupid joke was
all about it's a bad joke but it's not
even that bad no I Prasad means a lot
coming from you I like it stupid the
reaction to so [ __ ] stoop it was
stupid and I felt like you know I wish
that you know I wish that things went
differently I wish that you know we had
a lot of fights behind the scenes I
won't get in all that I don't think I
honestly I think it's good I think it's
good to I I don't I don't you know I I
feel like I did what was right for them
and I felt like we would have just come
to this impasse again so I was like
let's just pull the band-aid off and get
to get this over with are you going to
do something that involves politics now
because clearly you have a deep passion
for this yeah I started a new youtube
channel that the first video got April
3rd is called Collins last stand and
crazy it's already funded on patreon
$38,000 of mine for yes well it's people
are doing that expression I do yeah
because I think it's powerful like there
are things worth dying for there are
things worth risking their the others so
I reached 39 thousand dollars a month
now and it's going to fall 39,000 a
month people it's going to fall I'm sure
it's going to fall people doing [ __ ]
dude people are talking people are
really trying to minimize this holy [ __ ]
that's a lot of [ __ ] money 39 grand a
month yes you're going to get 39,000 a
months and you haven't even started yet
yeah technically but but this is it's
going to fall back down to the teens
founders or whatever science relax with
your humility well take it down if you
will if you scroll here you'll see on
the left side underneath the number my
only stretch goal was to reach $10,000
so my my expectations were blown out of
the water
right I really would I read into this
show is you know people are just sick of
this [ __ ]
to them this is them speaking and being
like we need a conduit that's going to
get into the history and get into the
philosophy in the politics but also that
will stand up and say like I'm not sorry
for a joke people have the right to make
mistakes people have the right to
express themselves it goes back to the
Confederate flag thing I might disagree
the person that flies that flag but I'm
not going to go wrap it up on their door
and pull it off and call them a racist
I'm just going to shake my head and walk
you know because there are other things
to worry about so it's people that like
want more Liberty focused individual
focus kind of things and and that's just
people speaking you to me you know
[Applause]
[Music]